hi i'm back again so sue me i like this
game i can't stop playing it also in my
spare time
i got the golds but i think i can do
better
i don't know i don't know why they don't
have any location challenges i mean it
would be take a lot longer and maybe
they're still testing it out but i'm
like oh man you know i kind of like i
kind of like cleaning the van as quickly
as possible like i got 229 and it's not
like that's an incredible time i don't
think anyway but i'm thinking that a sub
two minute time is possible i wasn't
really doing it
super intensely so i thought that maybe
i don't know maybe i could try so i
actually found out that you can uh pause
for a moment here it's kind of like a
little bit better but anyway
yeah anyway i'm
gonna hold on
let me play my game let me play the game
i want to play
let me play the games i don't know why
this is here the freaking challenge that
that's there
anyway
i don't know if uh this is going to be a
good one i i i'm kind of really i'm
bonesing it up all over the place now i
don't know what i'm doing
what am i even doing with my life what
am i doing i'm playing power wash
simulator i don't even know anymore
i don't understand who i am what i'm
trying to do who i'm trying to be i
don't understand anything anymore man
the tires are the the biggest problem i
mean you'd think that the grill or
something would be the biggest problem
but honestly i find the tires to be the
most annoying of all these okay grill
done bumper is not done i know that
why are you not done i don't know ah
bumpers and there we go bumper's finally
done my god this is worse this is worse
time this is a terrible time this is
awful time this time is bad time's bad
time's bad bro time's bad bad time is
bad it's oh come on i know it's not
actually timing me here but time is
still bad come on there we go
that stupid ladder i hate that ladder i
hate the letter ladder is destroying my
times come on it's clean
ah
this is the worst is terrible this is
awful this is the worst time i've ever
had in my life i feel awful and i feel
that everything is going downhill for me
it's because i'm talking you know and
the other times i wasn't talking so
after this one and it's terrible time
that it's going to give me i'm going to
take my time and i'm actually going to
try to concentrate on it
oh god i'm ruining everything it's awful
i'm doing the soap all wrong i'm doing
everything all wrong
see i gotta go in with these details if
you don't do the soap right yeah end up
doing all this over again
yep and then i've got doors left what is
that about i don't know which door is
done yes
terrible
is terrible is literally the worst i've
never been worse than this
[Music]
uh terrible 241 awful literally couldn't
be any worse i feel terrible about
myself and i think i've brought shame
on everyone i've ever known and loved
that is awful that was literally the
worst i could ever do in my life i've
never done worse and i never will do
worse than what i just did
so now i'm gonna concentrate
[Music]
this bumper should be done this bumper
should be done there we go grill should
be done come on there we go
[Music]
oh my god come on
come on ah come on
[Music]
oh what am i missing what am i missing
back bumper wheels lights doors hubcap
the hubcap what hubcap no my time
damn it oh
that hurts how did i forget a hubcap i
don't know there we go let's let's go
with the middle uh let's try this
[Music]
come on you should be done
come on
that should be done i don't know why
it's not probably because i'm not using
the longo
get done
what is with you
[Music]
come on what's left what's left come on
what's left
yes
two seconds god damn it if i hadn't got
off i hadn't missed all if i hadn't
missed some of those smaller spots
that would have been an even better time
but it was good i guess
[Music]
oh
man i know i could do better i know i
can do better okay let's keep it short
let's go for the metal cleaner first and
let's go straight for the roof
because this seems to be the one that
takes a lot of time the soap doesn't
seem to do as good as it should do by
the way
come on
oh my god i freaking hate you
[Music]
i feel like i've done incredibly worse
so i'm gonna try that again
i think probably a two minute time would
be possible if you do it exactly how you
should
[Music]
i'm going to do
glass cleaner first
i don't know why but i feel like getting
the doors is not the worst idea in the
world
[Music]
nope
this is awful
terrible terrible terrible terrible i
know i can get a better time on this i
know i can i know i can i can at least
get below 220.
[Music]
nah okay i think i know the right
methodology
i need to
give it a once-over with the widest
because it helps me
clean things off later
if i at least get a lot of the gunk
off of the
things that i need to go over in detail
and then once i give it a once-over
the next pass should be easier
i say as that tire fails to clean
[Music]
okay those tires both failed to clean
great
[Music]
tire
oh that's done okay never mind it was
that tired god i'm an idiot
okay maybe there's still time let's see
how this goes
[Music]
ah come on where's oh come on my time
come on
wow
oh so
it's gonna be such a good time
i mean of course i beat my record but
also god damn it the body
sub two minutes totally possible it's
totally possible
[Music]
how is that tire not getting cleaned
how is this tire not getting cleaned
what oh because it's not unclean oh my
god it was the one behind it
uh and then the body is it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter doesn't
freaking matter
god of course just oh my god you're
killing me game all right this one's
gonna be the one
oh come on no
no
no oh
i had such ah that was so close to two
minutes
oh and i got me and i got a new one
that's good it's good and all it's good
it's good i'm very happy with myself but
also i'm very disappointed in myself
[Music]
oh my god come on come on what the hell
god damn you
[Music]
come on
i get a better time but god it always
robs me of more every time
[Music]
i just want to feel good about the one
that i do get
[Music]
oh come on no
no what no what oh the wing mirrors oh i
forgot
god
no
no that was such a good run no
[Applause]
oh
no
how could i forget the wing mirror
okay well if you're gonna take that long
then shut up
[Music]
hello god
oh my god
what
oh metal god
damn me to hell and back
[Music]
hmm i wonder
would that be a better strategy
[Music]
well i mean i would be doing well but
the doors are still
unclean okay it's not the worst strategy
if if maybe i focused that a little bit
better
[Music]
[Applause]
to 12
oh my god i did it
to 12.
oh
oh i've been playing this way too long
okay i'm gonna wrap this one up but i
got 212 and that's about as quick as i
can get it and that's with me really
wang doodling it and kind of being
reckless about it i bet i could do it
better
um with the technique that i'm going at
but
at the same time i feel like
there's only so much that i can do so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below i know that i love this
game too much but i love this game so
much and maybe i could play it
competitively maybe i just need to see
someone do it better thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down the comments below and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you